[Musique]
josé tu dis que tu es le candidat de
l'écologie et du social mais
concrètement le rapport entre les deux
je vois pas trop quoi
écoute c'est simple je vais prendre deux
exemples les ogm et le nucléaire
aujourd'hui le nucléaire ça représente
énormément d'argent
sacré très peu d'emplois alors qu'il y à
une alternative avec les énergies
renouvelables c'est cela qu'il faut
aujourd'hui développée pour les ogm
aujourd'hui multinationales veulent
imposer ces semences transgéniques
on sait qu'elles sont dangereuses pour
l'environnement parce qu'il ya un risque
aujourd'hui de contamination généralisée
elles sont dangereuses pour la santé
parce que les premières études le
démontrent et en même temps elle prive
les paysans de leur liberté tous les
cinq minutes en europe il ya une ferme
qui disparaît et en plus l'agriculture
aujourd'hui est en pleine dérive avec
des gros problèmes d'environnement des
gros problèmes de crise sanitaire comme
on l'a vu ces dernières années on voit
bien que la logique productiviste avec
son cortège de produits chimiques et des
gm on va bien que les politiques
libérales au sens large du terme de
conduisent tout droit à la faillite à la
faille de la planète à l'heure actuelle
alimentation fait 1500 kilomètres pour
arriver dans notre assiette
c'est un scandale sur le plan des de
l'économie d'énergie et sur le plan
d'eau du climat alors que l'on peut
produire une alimentation saine à
proximité ce que je constate dans cette
campagne c'est qu'il ya énormément de
d'initiatives qui foisonnent et
notamment d'autres façons de produire et
si on est capable de s'affranchir de la
loi du fric et du marché bien un autre
monde est en marche et je crois vraiment
que c'est possible non oui c'est
possible
les amap en sont un bon exemple puisque
c'est une alternative qui permet à
l'agriculteur de sortir des coups d'une
marché
de la spirale infernale du toujours plus
goûteux sont moins chers
pour aller dans le qualitatif et pour
produire une vraie une rupture des amap
c'est une association pour le maintien
d'une agriculture paysanne
c'est un système très simple quiero mais
le paysan au coeur de son rôle qui est
un rôle nourricier donc des familles se
regroupent entre elles dans un quartier
est face à un partenariat avec une ferme
le plus près possible de chez elle et
elle s'engage il a vite cette ferme
vis-à-vis du fermier lui dix produits on
veut des produits sains diversifié de
saison et en contrepartie on se partage
ce que vous allez récolter se partage
entre nous ce que vous avez réglé on
s'engage financièrement à l'avant ce
temps josé bové dit il faut que
l'agriculture rempli sa fonction de
souveraineté alimentaire
ça me convient bien parce que sermet
l'agriculture sur l'ensemble des
continents au service de l'ensemble des
populations c'est la lutte contre la
malbouffe et se déliter de dire que la
santé l'environnement et finalement
d'être humain doit passer avant
l'économique avant tout ce qui est
marchandise et ça doit être prioritaire
en toute chose
[Musique]
nous ne voulons pas que des
multinationales a service les semences
des paysans au nom de ces valeurs nous
allons agir les commettre un acte
illégal mais légitime
[Musique]
70% des européens sont contre les ogm
mais combien de personnes sont allées en
prison pour défendre la société contre
ces multinationales de l'agro business
josé est unique dans ce domaine josé là
on est au coeur du système je pense que
tu dois te sentir dans son élément non
avec des moulins owen véritable
cauchemar capitaliste celui qui a la
voix organise la misère sociale et
détruit la planète
alors on peut sauver la planète selon
toi il faudrait mettre tout le monde au
chômage on arrête de produire on arrête
de travailler maintenant justement
contraire il faut à la fois lutter pour
faire en sorte que chacun puisse avoir
un revenu et travailler et en même temps
changer la façon de produire aujourd'hui
on peut pas continuer de détruire la
plaie toujours produire plus il faut en
même temps que nos modes de consommation
changent nos modes de vie et qu'à partir
de là on permette à chacun de pouvoir
vivre décemment
la campagne de josé bové c'est la seule
campagne qui est vraiment du 21e siècle
parce que justement elle n'oppose pas
l'urgence sociale et l'urgence
écologique il faut préserver la planète
et pour ça il faut que tout le monde ait
des bonnes conditions de vie il faut que
le logement soit de haute qualité
environnementale
il faut que les emplois soient des
emplois utiles il faut qu'on réponde aux
besoins sociaux
il n'y a pas de contradiction entre
l'urgence sociale et l'urgence
écologique et urgence écologique urgence
sociale ça veut dire pour moi que l'âme
la maison brûle la planète brûlent les
voitures brûlent c'est parce
qu'aujourd'hui au centre des décisions
politiques
seul le profit compte on veut que
l'emploi le travail ça soit pas des
variables d'ajustement
ça sera pas l'occasion de gagner un
maximum de fric on n'est pas des citrons
on n'est pas là pour être pressé
on veut affirmer haut et fort que tout
le monde est indispensable au
fonctionnement de la société on a besoin
de tout le monde au 21e siècle il est
temps que le travail et les salariés
soient valorisés mais aussi que
l'environnement soit protéger valoriser
le travail c'est permettent la
sécurisation du parcours des
travailleurs s'est aussi assuré lynn
augmentations de salaire et permettre à
ceux qui ne travaillent pas de pouvoir
le faire
c'est aussi lutter contre les cadences
infernales mais il faut en même temps
protéger l'environnement défendre la
biodiversité lutter contre l'effet de
serre et promouvoir des énergies
renouvelables par exemple le 22 avril
chacun peut le dire avec son bulletin de
vote josé bové un autre avenir est
possible
[Musique]